[Music]
welcome back guys another episode of mi
the [ __ ] we get the judge people you
could judge people in comments we're
gonna judge them just a lot of judgment
going on it's really hot right that's
horny yep that's what's that horny
experienced horniest experienced how
horny this how horny is it wait horny
was she so this one's about cancer
extremely horny too horny so am I the
[ __ ] for not shaving my head a long
time back co-workers in support of a
co-worker with cans no you know what if
your head looks weird like my head would
look weird well your hair doesn't grow
fast
my head looks awesome right now look so
weird if I shave my mom she used to
smooth the back of my head when I was a
baby she would sculpt to the skull
you're supposed to do that I'm worried
what is that baby laying down their head
I think my mom just left my head on the
pillow for too long that's why cuz if
you lay back like that you get a flat
head yeah cuz baby's bones are still a
little malleable so you can either
flatten it or you can we can shape it
into like this I look at it as it as a
joke I work at a gas station and I have
for over a year it's got a small subway
inside and we have a staff of eight on
the gas station side the subway has a
staff of 10
our assistant manager on the gas side
was diagnosed with cancer and as it
usually happens shaved her hair when it
began to fall out from the chemo
everyone in the store has decided to
shave their heads and support everyone
both gas station side and the subway
side so that's a total of 17 people
girls - that doesn't really say but it
says everyone I'm sure there's females
working out well I'm the only one who
won't and I'm being treated very passive
aggressively I'm getting snide comment
from time to time when customers ask why
everyone shaved their heads all my
co-workers give sarcastic responses
clearly aimed at me
it's been a few weeks and I'm getting
frustrated I mentioned it to my manager
and she gave me something she gave me
something how they're frustrated that
not everyone seems fully committed to
wishing our assistant manager good luck
so there is a one
here cuz he's talking to a female
manager so this says I am a 27 year old
guy I haven't cut my hair in five years
other than basic trims to remove data
into groumet I'm proud of my hair
I've only proud of my hair though he
probably has some really long like metal
hair proud of his hair
I've only cut my hair once since I
turned 18 I know it sounds stupid but
I'm very proud of my hair I suffer from
major depression and my hair is one
thing in my life I feel like I have
control over if that makes sense
okay plus I've never found a short
hairstyle that made me feel comfortable
or when I looked good in am I the
[ __ ] for not cutting my hair along my
coworkers to support a co-worker
diagnosed with cancer well sounds like
he's got his own issues I had an uber
driver like this guy he was he is Hugh
stole powder his hair my hair is over
and you start talking about his hair and
he's like keep my hair also has an
Instagram he's like pulling my hair
become a fan of my hair on Instagram
is this the guy is this the guy he's in
California oh my god is the hair yeah I
would not shave my [ __ ] head me
neither but also like for girls I feel
like it's a little bit different like
you know there's a lot of femininity
attached to like your hair and stuff
whereas a guy and then maybe is me being
sexist but like guys hair grows out like
pretty fast to the length that it was Oh
it's sexist like he's my hair does not
grow up that it depends on the guy and
also like you shouldn't be forced to do
anything it's yeah it's your body like
you shouldn't be forced or feel like
yeah because what if it was religious
and I don't think this is the only way
to show support maybe he doesn't even
like that manager to other ways to
support somebody you know if you're the
only one you are the [ __ ] a little
bit but what about when you go out at
night and [ __ ] now you got a shaved head
and it looks weird and you're not at
work
no dude with the shades it looks weird
their head no say it looks with his
confidence right the threesome sure sure
sure then he goes out his his conference
is suffering he can't do totally that's
why when he talked about like the the
back story behind why he is attached to
his hair again
like we're like I feel him but this is
kind of like he's got a he's dealing
with his own issues they're like that's
not unrelated to wanting to support
imagine Julian with a shape so cancer is
not a not work issue so it's like people
are just bright like I mean egging in
the centimorgan but it's not
work-related yeah there shouldn't be any
not I mean to just force
non-work-related things into the
workplace and make it like a mandatory
thing or just [ __ ] on people because of
it it's kind of [ __ ] up yes bite the
cause you know that's why I divert back
to my original you are not the [ __ ]
I mean what if like everybody at work
regrets like shaving their head and so
now that was hella pissed and then but
then they try to cover it with a good
reason you know so that they're like
good people and the inside even though
like they're hella jealous or they're
just hating on the fact is like [ __ ]
where I commit to something so long-term
that I didn't even think that like what
what I thought was a scheme she doesn't
even have cancer but everybody was
jealous of how nice his hair was so then
the whole scheme was a game like one of
those he could be kind of like one of
those like metal guys where your hair is
kind of tied to your identity definitely
sounds like this that's kind of a thing
that cuz like for a while like I was
into like a very alternative scene and I
like to having gauges and piercings and
stuff and when we see other people like
out in public that have like similar
characteristics whether it's like a bad
t-shirt or one of us yeah you like feel
like oh that's one of my people and so
to lose that with that being his hair it
could be something to do with his
identity it's definitely part of his
identity yeah you saying that pretty
good yeah how come you don't say
anything in the meeting when everyone's
like hey we should all share there yeah
I'm all like [ __ ] no I mean he probably
did nobody [ __ ] that [ __ ] on right cuz
what's [ __ ] up about it is no matter
what like he could say like okay I'm
gonna open up right now like yeah like I
have confidence issues and my hair is
really important to me and they're like
she has cancer you [ __ ] like she has
cancer like that's the ultimate like
fall out of it my answer would be a lot
of people have cancer
see that'll be good they'll be good
equal half cancer and then you get you
to our work not just for not shaving
your head but because he's the he's a
lot of people have cancer good yeah
that's one of the main reasons why I
can't hold down a job created your own
yeah I hate [ __ ] like this and this this
is such a normal thing to happen
there's so much pettiness that goes on
in the company that I am so glad I don't
have to [ __ ] deal with I hey that's
the number one thing that drove me crazy
it's like this is all this extra [ __ ]
workplace [ __ ] it's like leave that [ __ ]
in high school man just go in do the
[ __ ] work do the business get the
[ __ ] out dude and like also if this was
like just about supporting somebody with
cancer why is it now about him yeah it's
not like he doesn't like her he doesn't
support her like it's it's just it
almost has nothing to do with the root
of the cause like you guys have already
shaved your head and you've executed the
statement I care why why do you does he
have to be a part of this or else I used
to work with a [ __ ] [ __ ] and when
it was time for his birthday we all did
this thing where it's like everyone
we're doing like 15 bucks to get a cake
or whatever I don't why they about
[ __ ] $150 case but we'll get to that
so yes so then it was it was his
birthday and like hey do you want to put
in 4 for his cake and I was like
honestly no I don't like that I don't
like that guy and they were like kind of
like what what me and my man but it's
like I'm just like he's always been [ __ ]
into me I just don't put it over the
cake and then they're kind of the chicks
were kind of snooty about the dude that
was funny it's like the office like
angela is putting together it was like
that
he's like friends when Ross moved into
the new building oh yeah and also I'm
like let's let's break in the spring
open the [ __ ] books why are these
cake soaked I just can't get soda and
Anna to 5004 the whole party yeah but
you want to pitch in I don't want to go
to this party yeah no you know you know
you can't eat the cake and I'm like yeah
I know I don't care I'm not gonna sing
happy birthday this whole you got a
drink the kool-aid in the company thing
like it's not even a part of the company
culture it's just some [ __ ] idea that
someone has and then they try to get
together and it's like not even official
thing they just want to have fun and I'm
just like man yeah
happen at my job like when the when the
kind of bow broke cuz that I'm assuming
by this point I will probably announce
it I like tweeting at this point I saw a
month left at work but one of the things
that happened was there were people at
my job that had that had a similar title
as me but we were all like linear linear
the right word in term interns rose it's
just these people had seniority so out
of respect I would always call this one
lady my boss and I would I was just like
yeah she's my boss she's my boss like
she had an office she's has a director
title I would say she's my boss but
technically she doesn't oversee anything
I do I report directly to the vice
president and so like they would always
tell me what she would always tell me
what to do and I'd just be like uh-huh
uh-huh
she took it too seriously yeah she took
it wait like I gave you this respect and
you abused it you know so sick to say I
only report to the vice president
well I still invest dude one day so like
one day she came in and had this whole
she tried to like like get mad at me
over some [ __ ] and I was like this is
really uncomfortable conversation but I
gotta let you know I report directly to
what he's president and she told me she
was like you're too smart for your own
good but like not as a compliment she's
basically saying if you you should just
be dumb and like head like head low and
just follow the crowd just be a sheep
and like that was kind of I already knew
I was leaving at that point but that was
the point rob was like this isn't gonna
work out because I'm not gonna sit here
and play [ __ ] stupid and just be a
sheep and the herd so did you walk any
like mr. vice president
I'm quitting now I've reported to my
corporation source they do make you feel
like you have to drink the kool-aid and
like it just straight up it's not for
everybody it is it it's really not cool
with it and they can deal with the
[ __ ] some people would rather have
that structure and security so they'll
go with it but yeah I know I don't like
being told what to do by anybody so yeah
there's I like to think of it the only
company in the world where you could
roast the [ __ ] out of your boss and talk
[ __ ] to him and everything will be fine
you could even crash into his car and
he's like don't worry about it normal
yeah he's like okay you
just taking I just think couples here
he's a pound charge family
yeah but the corporate world is kind of
weird I don't know I only want to get
back into it when I'm financially stable
so I could say quit whenever I want but
I want to go in there just to be
aggressive with people yeah cuz there's
no consequences you really want they
give you a certain title you do like
whatever basically like whatever you
want you're getting tenure that's what I
said to Steve I was like if I had like
[ __ ] you money I would go open a
restaurant like I own like a whole
restaurant bar situation and then be a
waitress and no one knows that I'm the
owner and just to like talk [ __ ] just to
do whatever the [ __ ] can I see the
manager works like you [ __ ] up before
the drink on him like I want to see the
manager II like I'm the manager what I
want even the managers and employees not
to know that I owned the bar so they
like try to reprimand me and I get
pulled in the office and I'm like let me
tell you something you can only do that
once manager no one knows why then the
new manager comes in no one knows I'm my
owners still probably the new manager
was someone that you promoted because
they you heard their sob story when you
were down and then you also gave him 10
grand yeah and then I put that video on
YouTube that is so Undercover Boss
Undercover Boss does that [ __ ] it's like
it's like this is Bob he has a
multi-billion dollar company and he's
like hey I met the fry cook he's really
cool give him like five g's he's got a
family proportionally [ __ ] nothing to
Bob I love it
[Music]